[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour la sorbonne
ça vous est déjà arrivé de partir en
randonnée et de réaliser après une deux
trois heures de marche que vous avez
oublié des sandwiches dans le frigo
qu'est ce qu'on fait dans ces cas là
quand on réalise qu'il va falloir tenir
une journée entière sur un seul paquet
de biscuits à ce sujet avec mes frères
clermont se bat
mais entre gens civilisés qu'est ce
qu'on fait on prend le paquet de
biscuits en distribuer entre les
randonneurs en espérant que ça tombe
juste et chacun mange ce biscuit quand
ils le souhaitent
à la fin de la journée on a mangé un
paquet de biscuits strictement pas une
miette de plus et chacun était libre de
ses choix
cette philosophie c'est la philosophie
de fondue quotas carbone individuel dont
j'aimerais vous parler aujourd'hui
mais avant ça remettons les choses en
perspective
après plus de 40 ans de négociations
internationales sur le climat la quasi
totalité des pays du monde s'est engagé
à atteindre la neutralité carbone d'ici
la seconde moitié du siècle
ce sera d'accord de paris
mais ça va pas assez vite
le dérèglement climatique quand je suis
né c'était des prévisions scientifiques
en d'abscon rapport de 50 pages mais
aujourd'hui c'est des faits d'actualité
inondations torrentielles en europe 1
100 dinars et table en amérique du nord
migrations causées par la progression de
la réalité en afrique tout ça était
prévu
et tout ça se réalise
la terre 10 et paul eluard à juste titre
est devenue bleue comme une orange
alors gensse la france a mis en place
une taxe carbone ya sept ans diluer dans
le prix de l'énergie devaient augmenter
progressivement de façon à orienter nos
comportements mais on a vite vu les
limites de ce système
payer une dizaine de centimes d'euros
supplémentaires par litre d'essence n'a
pas le même effet selon que vous êtes au
rsa ou vous gagnez un smic par jour
parce que oui ça existe
dans le premier cas ça peut vous
empêcher satisfaire vos besoins
fondamentaux comme de vous chauffer par
exemple dans l'autre cas ça change rire
à votre consommation
autrement dit la taxe carbone était soit
trop faible pour être efficace
soit trop inégalitaire pour être
acceptable et donc père aimant
comment atteindre la neutralité carbone
dans un esprit de justice sociale alors
on pourrait commencer par transformer la
taxe carbone à rendre plus égalitaire en
redistribuant une partie de ses revenus
aux plus défavorisés mais après abby
gilet jaune
ça risque de prendre beaucoup de temps
avant de reconstruire la confiance
alors on pourrait tout miser sur la
technologie d oui si demain matin on
trouver une solution pour se débarrasser
des déchets nucléaires ou recycler les
terres rares contenues dans les énergies
renouvelables le problème climatique
serait quasi résolu quasi mais ce serait
un pari
aujourd'hui on peut plus permettre de
faire un pari
alors on pourrait interdire
interdire tout simplement la
consommation de viande la possession
d'une résidence secondaire les voyages
en avion peu importe toutes ces
consommations évitables pourrait être
interdite
regarde le chaos climatique mais je
pense que ni vous ni moi n'avons envie
de confier de telles prérogatives à
l'état
alors nous voilà au point de départ
comment
allier la liberté de la taxe carbone
c'est à dire la liberté de choisir sa
propre consommation à l'efficacité de
l'interdiction
le tout dans un esprit de justice
sociale
ça ressemblait d'impasse mais
souvenez-vous de mon histoire de paquets
de biscuits en randonnée si on faisait
exactement la même chose
avec des gaz à effet de serre
je m'explique chaque année une agence
d'état
définiraient un volume d'émission
maximum à ne pas dépasser pour respecter
l'accord de paris ce volume dont on
retirerait les émissions collective
serait divisé en parts strictement et
gagnent pas résidents français
chacun aurait donc une forme de conte
carbone qui sera renflouée
automatiquement chaque année est débité
à chaque consommation de produits
carbonés alors qu'elle produit vous me
direz un litre d'essence évidemment un
téléphone une classe de théâtre une
andouillette au restaurant peu importe
en fait aujourd'hui tout produit et met
directement ou indirectement des gaz à
effet de serre dont tous produits
devraient être concernés par ce
dispositif
est ensuite l'entreprise le restaurant
la troupe de théâtre
répercutera ses émissions de production
sur le consommateur tout comme
aujourd'hui elles répercutent ces coûts
de production
le premier avantage d'un tel dispositif
ce serait de respecter les budgets
carbone nationaux et c'est pas rien la
france n'a jamais réussi à le faire et
c'est principalement dû à une chose les
instruments économiques et des normes
écologiques en général sont des
instruments relatifs je prends un
exemple tout de suite vous prenez les
normes d'émissions des voitures en
grammes de co2 par kilomètre ça paraît
efficace
mais si à la fin d'année vous roulez
toujours plus
bas vous émettrez toujours plus
émettre moins de co2 par kilomètre par
kilo de boeuf produit par m² de
logements même par point de pib ça
favorisera mais ça ne garantira jamais
la réduction d'émissions
à carbonne fondé sur une logique de
contraintes non plus relative mais
absolue permettrait de contourner cette
impasse
deuxième point qui permettrait d'être
résolue réduire les inégalités dans le
processus de décarbonation
là où aujourd'hui la taxe carbone frappe
le premier senti litres d'essence
consommés par la boulangère qui sera en
travail à 5 heures du mat et qui est
payé au smic le quota exonérer les
besoins fondamentaux par construction il
ne toucherait que les consommations
évitables obligeant la catégorie de
population les plus aisés
à faire des choix mais au lieu de
confier à l'état le soin de restreindre
certaines consommations prendre l'avion
manger de la viande chacun serait libre
de choisir ce à quoi ils souhaitent
relancer pourquoi par exemple
interdire à une voyageuse passionnés de
prendre l'avion une fois de temps en
temps si par ailleurs elle est
strictement végétarienne n'achète rien 9
que ce soit des vêtements ou des
produits électroniques et n'a pas de
voiture
à ce stade vous devez normalement avoir
beaucoup de questions la première
d'entre elles c'est souvent qu'est ce
qu'on ferait en cas de quotas
excédentaires si à la fin d'année on a
des côtés avec sédentaires ça dépendra
de votre philosophie politique
soit vous adhérez à la notion de droits
à polluer dans ce cas une personne
détentrice de quotas pourra les revendre
sur un marché carbone soit au contraire
vous considérez que les gaz à effet de
serre sont une pollution irréversible
il ne peut donc pas être monnayés
financiarisé dans ce cas l'agent et à
récupérer les quotas contre
indemnisation puis les détruire on peut
aussi envisager une solution
intermédiaire où il serait possible
d'acheter et de revendre des quotas dans
une certaine limite
deuxième cas peut-être plus importante
encore comment faire pour ces personnes
qui faute de revenus ne peuvent pas
isoler leur logement qui est une
passoire thermique et ne peuvent pas
changer leur véhicule qui est très
polluant et donc ces personnes excèdent
leur quota carbone avant même la fin
d'année
vous répondre à ça il faudra réorienter
une partie des aides publiques à la
transition
là où aujourd'hui elles financent de
façon souvent généraliser
le changement de véhicule ou la pose de
panneaux solaires elles devront se
focaliser sur la décarbonation des
besoins fondamentaux des personnes les
plus défavorisées
mais les personnes les plus favorisés
seront pas moins incités à isoler leur
logement ou à changer leur véhicule
parce qu'elle souhaiteront conserver
leur quota pour d'éventuels loisirs
troisième et dernier point
comment faire avec ses émissions
importés vous savez que tous les
téléphones qu'on a dans nos poches ce
soit apple ou samsung
sont pas produits en france ça serait
donc toutes les émissions liées à votre
consommation ont lieu à l'extérieur de
la france chaque français mais en
moyenne une tonne de co2 en chine chaque
année un chiffre du haut conseil pour le
climat
alors comment les prendre en compte dans
notre système
en vérité en ce moment même la
commission européenne réfléchit à une
taxe carbone aux frontières ce qui veut
dire que nous avons l'information
carbone sur les produits qu'on importe
donc il sera possible d'intégrer les
émissions apporté dans le dispositif
sans trop de questions serait légitime à
quel âge on aurait nos premiers quotas
carbone
comment faire avec ces biens qui sont
très émissifs à la construction mais qui
ensuite permettent un comportement plus
vertueux comment faire pour adapter le
quota carbone individuel au mode de vie
ruraux urbains ou insulaires
je sens la curiosité qui pétille dans le
regard
mais je pourrais pas y répondre j'aurais
pas le temps y en a trop ce que je veux
vous transmettre avant tout c'est ma
conviction que le quota carbone
individuel permettrait d'allier trois
choses que nous sommes incapables
d'allier aujourd'hui la radicalité et
collectives c'est-à-dire la certitude
d'atteindre l'accord de paris la
neutralité carbone
la liberté individuelle maximale l'état
ne viendra pas vous expliquez vous que
vous devez pas prendre l'avion ou
consommé de la viande vous ferez vos
choix en conscience dans cette limite
et la justice sociale alors oui le
dispositif pas rien un peu complexe
mais franchement pour un pays comme la
france qui a inventé la tva devrait pas
nous inquiéter
n'est ce pas une blague la france a
inventé la tva et maintenant ça
représente la majorité des budgets de
plus de 150 pays dans le monde alors en
france on essaie de briller autrement
avec les macarons ladurée la tour eiffel
les sous-marins face à en essayer mais
transfert de messi au psg mais tout ça
on pourrait briller autrement imaginez
seulement dans trente ans la france a
atteint le monde attend la neutralité
carbone sur la base de deux choses
l'accord de paris de paris
et le quotas carbone individuel imaginez
mis en place pour la première fois en
france
un dernier point
sa fédé henning qu'on parle de sobriété
figure même dans la loi nous sommes là
pour faire joli sobriété énergétique
sobriété numérique mais c'est vrai c'est
joli
mais la vraie sobriété
la culture de sobriété
nécessitera une bifurcation bien plus
profonde alors les mondes culturels et
associatifs commence à décoloniser nos
imaginaires pour reprendre l'expression
de serge latouche mais ça risque de ne
pas aller assez vite
en matérialisant très concrètement au
quotidien une limite environnementale
dans l'intégralité de nos échanges
le quota carbone individuel permettrait
de retisser ses liens rompus entre notre
économie est vraiment
si je vous ai convaincu creuser l'idée
a des complexes très riche elle présente
mille avantages et 1000 inconvénients et
peu importe les points que j'ai mis
devant vous aujourd'hui elle mérite
d'être débattue
si je ne faisais pas convaincu ce que
j'envisage
garde accueille mis des sous le coude
pour les repas de famille ça vous
changera des discussions sur le pass
sanitaires et croyez moi ce sera pas mon
ami mais je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
là